sur la place joyeuse nous revivons une
époque où le port de la tenue
traditionnelle est de rigueur
elles sont partout ces femmes
d'habitation vêtues de robes blanches en
coton et comme aujourd'hui c'est jour de
fête
les matadors présente également ont tenu
à se distinguer les matadors de jus
également des semis en coton extrêmement
travaillé pour nous prouver
elles viennent en plus rajouté et haute
en couleurs elles sont comparés aux
geisha car elles ont la capacité
d'entretenir une conversation elle
possède beaucoup d'argent ils sont
repoussés par les autres femmes comme
celle ci à la robe rayée à la coiffe
imposante le port du chapeau et d'
interdit aux femmes de couleur
ainsi elle ne devait pas montré leur jeu
sur cette place
plein d'autres personnages issus des
habitations
même les moins bien intentionnés sociaux
collomb je suis un collant et moi je
suis venue acheter des esclaves
ça me demande beaucoup de temps et je
suis un peu navré patronale pas à
trouver ses hommes forts au quai d'orsay
il ne participera pas à la fête celui ci
trop préoccupé le mariage débute
maintenant nous sommes dans les salons
de la mairie
les maris esquisse leurs premiers pas de
valse les invités sont conquis
impeccable j'aime bien pas trop mal ce
soir et on l'apprend bonne chose et on
voit le dire une chose des tableaux très
proche de la réalité de la vie d'antan
cette manifestation participer aux
actions de protection et de mise en
valeur du patrimoine qu'on a tendance à
mettre notre vêtements traditionnels
dans le cannabis est au combat que nous
menons contre le fait qu'aujourd'hui
nous venons se trouve dans du carnaval
l'important pour nous c'est de faire en
sorte et des martiniquais se réapproprie
du vêtement traditionnel mêmes
moderniser s'il faut aller dernier
regard sur le passé ou plutôt sur la
tradition coup de scène avec les
pêcheurs un héritage bien conservé
aujourd'hui encore
[Applaudissements]